hey everybody what is going on as you
can tell by the title of this video we
are going to be building iron man well
portions of iron man his head
a foot and a hand
but we will build an entire iron man
mark three when it's all said and done
now this is a courtesy of fan home they
are the distributors of this very cool
iron man mark 3 set now it obviously
comes from spain as you can tell by the
packaging here espanol from altaya but
fan home will be distributing this uh
through various different locations so
if you want to find out more you can
actually check out their website below
because they also do marvel and star
wars collectibles and they are
officially licensed so if you're worried
about that do not be now i want to walk
you through the first three issues that
we've got here now as you can sel tell
the prices are different and we're not
going to give you the exact prices
because they do vary based on the
country that you're located in and also
fan homes pricing as well but uh if you
do get the subscription you also get the
free ironman base that goes along with
it we'll show you what that looks like
with a mock-up when it's all said and
done
but today we're going to show you uh the
head a hand and a foot and one cool
thing about this setup is that it's all
metal there's batteries involved this is
a model folks this is not some
plastic toy or something for kids this
is something that's going to be for
adult collectors out there or for some
serious collectors and this has 52
articulation points on it as i mentioned
lighting to it but the height of this is
actually very impressive it comes in at
60 cm and just to kind of give you a
sense for the american folks out there
who don't go by centimeters that is
roughly about 24 inches so this is 60 cm
right here so as you can tell this is
even taller than a quarter inch scale
hot toys figurine
uh it's about 10 centimeters taller than
that and that's not including the base
so if you look at this display cabinet
behind us courtesy of terra vault here
we now actually have to move a couple of
the shelves to actually put iron man
inside of this that's how tall it is so
if this is something that you're
interested in i mean do take note of the
size and the scale of it and also the
requirements because you're gonna have
to know a little bit of mechanical
know-how there is an instruction manual
that is in each of the issues kind of
gives you a little bit of the history a
little bit of comics and then it get
walks you through the instructions now
for this uh setup here it's all in
spanish so we're going to rely on images
mainly and luck but when you order it
from fan home it will be in english so
with that i think we're going to get out
and get down to this and then as we go
through it i'll show you some of the how
it works and how it looks through some
various of the images here now as you
can tell we got the first three issues
here we'll put the second and third
issue aside
they're relatively small in size here in
terms of this right you can obviously
fold it like this or not the the first
issue is going to be the largest i think
and it only says 1.99 euro but
this is just to start things off
it does get more expensive as you can
tell as things go uh go on it also
depends on how many parts you have
inside of it but let's look at this
first off you can have a battery because
you're gonna need a battery to light up
his helmet
and then you have these uh
there's a bit uh some paperwork inside
of this let's take a look here we've got
some you know some things if you
subscribe you can get some exclusive uh
products again these are all in spanish
but i guess they'll have this in english
as well for you so do take that in mind
but the most important is going to be
these two books um this is going to be
the uh
this is going to give you the old fold
out here so you can get a sense of the
scale of what iron man is
you get a poster you can put on your
wall if you want to do that then on the
back of it i'm going to show you how it
all looks so how it lights up for model
three
you can uh display it the base lights up
all this comes into play you've got a
battery charger you got hats you got
t-shirt all that fun stuff that you can
get with this as well and that is what
the end result will look like is right
here that's essentially what this is
put this to the side
[Applause]
and then of course
we have
the issue as they called the scubre la
historia the iron man which means
history of iron man
in an issue it comes with a battery in
the back of it and inside of this
you're going to see gives you some
information some trivia about iron man
uh the origins of him and then you get
into the instruction manual how to uh
put this piece together as you can see
right here so you've got the mascara
my spanish is not that great but you
guys can figure it out and put it
translate into english but you get all
the tools and you also get a screwdriver
here as well
do not lose this because you're going to
need this throughout all the issues that
come into play because there's small
screws but don't worry they're all
labeled in respective bags so you kind
of know where everything goes but it
looks awesome man i mean this just looks
really really cool
uh
you know geek culture always puts me in
these situations where i gotta build
things and put things together that i
don't even know about but that's the fun
part you're gonna go along with me on
this journey and through my frustration
hopefully it's not too frustrating
because i'm uh not great with small
screws
and uh screwdrivers and stuff like that
i like power drills man i like big
things yeah
biceps
not ready yet
got to get to the gym more i got my
booster shot out of wait two weeks
anyway that's another story for another
day but nonetheless uh
yeah
let's get down to it so
let's let's see the back of this
paperwork as well if you want to see
what it looks like there okay let's go
with the information i have to say
though um just giving you just my first
impressions i haven't even taken this
out of the package is that the paintwork
looks fantastic as i mentioned before
this is all metal right for the most
part i mean there'll be some plastic
pieces of course but it's predominantly
metal so this is not going to be like
your typical hot toys uh figurine out
there this is a metallic model
that lights up and is just going to be
it's going to be a conversation starter
if somebody comes your home and sees
this it's going to be awesome
i just don't know how many issues it's
going to take to build it we'll find out
but i guess fan home will give you more
information information when you click
on the link in the description below by
the way
if you click on that link below you're
interested in this this is an exclusive
discount for geek culture uh subscribers
and watchers of course of this video so
subscribe to the channel if you can like
this video and you also can get a
special discount doesn't cost you
anything more actually it'll cost you
less by clicking on that link below they
might go into fan homes website directly
so keep that in mind
okay
xeno let's get down to it
i guess i can tear it off right
yep good all right
okay
looks like we've got some parts here
holy cow these screws are small
oh she's
i should have brought eyeglasses you got
my glasses you know well yeah i'm on you
but i might i need to borrow those from
you okay
holy cow this is
okay this is intricate
let's take out the piece let's take out
the main oh this is heavy oh this is
heavy
filling this part of the helmet right
here
this is all metal
this is impressive
very very impressive okay let's put that
to the side here
and then we've got all these other parts
here which i don't want to take out yet
because i don't want to drop these
things okay
[Applause]
here's the battery
by the way these are cr102 so just in
case you drop these or lose these
cr1025 is what you need to know to
replace that battery if you need to do
so but very cool they send batteries
because a lot of places don't send
betters okay let's get down to it
oh this is all in spanish
bless my heart
this kind of like babble you're gonna
learn spanish by the time you're done
with building this damn thing where's em
at a
guys this will be a lot easier for you
at home trust me this is going to take
some time um it's not that difficult but
it is very time consuming so i don't
think you want to see me put every
single screw inside of this helmet or in
the other part so we're going to do is
get zacky and gerald here at culture
they're going to help me put this thing
together and then we want to show you
the final pieces built up guys you ready
yeah let's do it come on
[Music]
all right so we just finished the helmet
the hand and the foot
zacky gerald and yonk came in for the
save to uh complete this
so i just want to walk through some of
the process for you guys because
obviously we sped through some of this
because you know we're not going to show
you every single screw that goes into
this for you model builders out there i
mean you're going to enjoy this you love
the nuances of putting things together
now if you're someone that isn't into
that you're more into like something
like a hot toys for example you take it
out of the box assemble the figurine
together pop on some of the accessories
you're good to go this is going to be a
much more intricate process it's not a
bad thing it's just how you approach it
so think of this as like an arts and
crafts project and that's sort of what
it is but the end result is actually
quite impressive i have to tell you i
mean let's start off with iron man's
left foot here i hope it's his left foot
it's his left foot i can tell you
there's a lot of weight on this um this
is a very beautifully made piece this
does not this is not plastic mind you
this is metal i mean there are some
plastic bits but the base of this is
metal in case in point it does light up
by pressing this button here you can see
it lights up
and i can show you that underneath here
as well
now there's a button here on the foot
that you're going to push to turn that
off and on now this cover here is
plastic but of course this is movable
and when you obviously would put the leg
on to it and everything else but the one
thing i have to say about that is even
from the metal to the plastic the paint
quality is fantastic so you don't notice
a difference going for metal plastic
which a lot of uh you know statues or
figurines or even models can sometimes
have this problem where you can really
notice the difference you're not going
to notice it in this piece at all which
is very impressive okay next we're going
to go to iron man's helmet now this is
quite intricate took us a while to get
this going because obviously our
instruction manual isn't spanish you
will get english mind you fan home.com
click on the link in the description
below you will get an english set sent
to you but this does work relatively
well just turn in the earpiece you can
see the eyes light up
so in terms of the helmet here there are
i mean it's again beautifully made but
there is something that i do want to
point out for you guys the
uh right ear area where you're going to
turn this to turn it on and off is a
little bit finicky i wish this was all
metal and i wish it was a little bit
more solid it's not a deal breaker
because once you this is not something
you're going to play with all the time
either going to turn it on or turn it
off
so but i do find it a little bit fidgety
the way that it's designed again this
could just be our copy because this is
sort of a pre-production sample you what
you'll get is the production units out
there but it's something to take note of
but overall i mean everything is
beautifully made it's got a lot of
weight to this now the hand took us
quite a bit of time because there's all
these little screws you have to put into
the fingers and remember 52 points of
articulation on this iron man mark iii
and a lot of it is in the hand itself
but this also turns on as well there's a
button here just like on the foot
turns on
look at that and then when you're done
push the button off and of course
put this there
and you're good to go so that's
essentially the three parts that we have
with us right now but i think you're
gonna have a lot of fun with this and i
think the end result is gonna be an
amazing ironman mark 3
model that is going to blow your mind in
terms of its build quality the color the
paintwork the detail it is really
awesome to see so once again as i
mentioned in this video a few times
already if you click on the link in the
description below from fanhome.com you
get an exclusive discount on the
subscription to get this ironman mark
iii and by the way if you're a star wars
fan they have r2d2 out there as well
which looks awesome
if you are a star wars fan you gotta
pick that up anyway those are our
thoughts
on
the iron man mark 3 from fan home
let us know your thoughts in the comment
section below is this something you're
looking to pick up any questions you
have on it hit us up and we'll try to
answer that for you with that follow us
on facebook subscribe to us subscribe to
the channel we got a lot of great
content coming like this video stay safe
and i'll chat to you soon take care
you